this one showed up on the eic channel
for recommendations and this channel
over here
if if you're wondering what this blue
writing is here it's it's basically a
chrome plug-in that i got it's it's free
it's called vid iq
and
it gives you a little bit more insight
as to you know what's going on with that
channel and you know if you look at
comments it it clearly shows you
something like the sub count so this is
all blue it pops out for me i notice it
right and this comment here from jack
and jc it's got 1.76 million subs
and uh this young man says the benefits
of long-term relationships versus
spinning plates for young men 18-28 if
any in your view apologies if you made a
video by the way love the mclaren had a
570 for a little bit so a young man in
his 20s had a mclaren and has a a
channel or had a mclaren
uh with 1.76 million subs so of course
i'm curious i click through
and we have their
channel over here
last video on this channel is a year ago
but it looks like
as i click over here
last video as we broke up
and then um
most people including myself they'll
list their other channels on the channel
tab so i click that go over to jack and
jc vlogs
and we have a brand new channel which
looks like they recently set up i don't
know what what happened the last one but
most recent uploads are she's getting
plastic surgery it looks like a boob job
and this one over here i watched it says
we did it and the thumbnail looks like
an engagement ring
so
this dude is asking for
advice on the benefits between uh dating
and ltr
coming from a strange place because he
because he has a youtube channel and i
watch this and it's like you know your
typical couple vlog i think is the best
way to describe it couple vlog is that
is that the right way i don't know
but they they just do dorky things
together and they film it and they put
it on youtube and people watch it and
they make money so you know good for
them
um we can pull this out and um
so since my inspiration came from
this young man let's let's deal with the
um
the idea of ltrs versus spinning plates
um
especially since he's an ltr using it to
make loads of money on youtube
so
um
let's define spinning plates first for
those that don't know what it is it's
just dating uh multiple women
simultaneously in a non-monogamous
fashion it's what women do women are
natural place spinners you know they
want to evaluate their options and um
choose the best they can get which is
why they'll date a bunch of guys women
are ever single um
anytime you run a woman anywhere you
might be by yourself
um
you have to understand women are never
single from from the sense that they
could be married could be engaged could
have a boyfriend could have multiple
boyfriends could be dating a bunch of
guys simultaneously could run at only
fans and have a thousand of thirsty beta
center her money every month could be
any number of those things but women
always have the attention of other guys
so
the notion of of spinning plates is
somewhat of a newer one it's awkward for
some guys to deal with but all it all it
really means is don't limit yourself to
one girl
uh deal with
several of them in a simultaneous
fashion it doesn't mean you got to be
intimate with all of them or you can be
it's up to you you can do whatever you
want you're a grown-ass adult at some
point in your life right so
when you reach that stage you know you
want to ask yourself well do i want to
invite women in my life in what capacity
do i want to invite women in my life do
i want to date them non-monogamous to me
by spinning plates or do i want to get
into an ltr
in jack's case getting into an ltr
worked out very very well for him uh he
built two youtube channels one with
almost two million subs and another one
approaching a hundred thousand uh
clearly doesn't have a problem with
money he's got a 570 and looks like he's
buying his girlfriend some boobies so
dude's doing quite well uh the ltr angle
for him worked out quite well now
last video on his last channel was we
broke up did they break up get back
together i don't know i don't have time
to do that much recon you guys can do
that if you want but
if if you follow that that stuff you can
let me know in the comments fill me in
so
the general advice that you're going to
get from on from an unplugged guy
is gonna be
just spin plates especially in your 20s
don't get into a long-term relationship
you don't know [ __ ] about women you
really don't i don't care if you grew up
around women if you had cousins if you
had sisters or not it doesn't matter
whatever your teacher told you whatever
you think you believe is is correct is
probably not going to serve you very
well
no that could be a fast track to a
university degree and oops i [ __ ] up
and i got the t-shirt too
which is fine you know there's many
different ways to learn things but
generally speaking most guys make a
colossal waste and they spend way too
much time from being honest chasing
girls
when they should be on a real purpose
chasing excellence making bank learning
game
maxing out on their looks
improving their status
understanding what frame is and how
women respond to frame in whether
short-term or long-term relationships
being captivating you know being a guy
that's interesting obviously
you know these are all some really
important components of your life that
you want to start building on
and the and the idea of wealth
should really start with your 20s
[Music]
every single multi-millionaire that i
know in their 30s started in their 20s
back to life every single
multi-millionaire that became a
multi-millionaire in their 40s started
in the 30s it's going to take you about
a decade to make serious bank okay it
doesn't happen overnight despite what
people are broadcasting out there and
trying to convince you of but your time
is far better off chasing excellence as
i defined not chasing women
most guys will chase girls
they chase the girls the first one that
touches his pp she you know he gets into
a long-term relationship with
and somewhere
down the road uh it generally doesn't
work out and then he's one of the guys
that calls in on one of my shows i've
got close to 200 shows now on
various playlists right now um and they
end up asking questions and why did i
screw up and how did i get caught up in
this mess sort of thing so
what are the benefits of an ltr from
jack's perspective he did a good job
good for him he's making loads of money
it's probably the right choice for him i
don't know much about it beyond that but
for the vast majority of guys out there
if you're not running a youtube vlog
a couple's youtube vlog you're far far
better off just
focusing on you and your purpose and
laying the foundation for yourself i'm
not saying don't deal with women don't
date women don't be intimate with a
woman i'm not saying any of those things
what i'm saying is your priorities
should be on yourself
and putting yourself first your goals
first and laying out the foundation for
your life
um again
when i say chase excellence i want to be
very very clear you're unplugged
you've maxed out or are maxing out on
your looks you're making bank or you're
starting to make serious bank you have
some status in the world you know men
want to be you women want to be with you
sort of thing you understand game which
is just what women essentially respond
to is all that means uh having good
frame with women when you're with them
on a long-term basis meaning they don't
walk all over you essentially and you're
a captivating guy you're not boring all
right you can do anything you want to
women except for bore them as the old
saying goes hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you